This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today, there are thousands of vacant homes all throughout Detroit. The motor city has been shrinking since the 1950s, but many of these vacancies stem from a decade ago when the financial crisis devastated the city. As I drove around, I'd seen abandoned home on almost every block. That's reporter Angus Chen, who we recently sent to Detroit. Many of these houses are still in good enough condition for someone to fix up and turn into a home. But a lot of them are damaged beyond repair.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。今天，底特律到处都有成千上万的空置房屋。这座汽车城自20世纪50年代以来一直在萎缩，但许多空置现象源于十年前那场摧毁了这座城市的金融危机。当我开车四处转悠时，几乎在每个街区都能看到废弃的房屋。那是记者安格斯·陈，我们最近派他去了底特律。这些房子中有很多状况依然良好，足以让人修缮并将其变成一个家。但其中许多已经损坏到无法修复的地步。
Without caretakers, they're roof-sacked in and their foundations crumbled, and their walls turned black from fire. And so, in 2014, Detroit started a city-wide demolition program to take down the houses that couldn't be fixed. The city estimated they had about 40,000 homes to demolish. Orlando Bailey is a community organizer from the east side of Detroit and he says the program's rollout was chaotic. They were really building the plan as they fly and I'm quoting a city official who said something like that at the time. Houses were coming down all over the city, but for a lot of residents they couldn't come down fast enough.
由于缺乏维护，它们的屋顶塌陷，地基崩裂，墙壁因火灾而变黑。因此，在2014年，底特律启动了一项全市范围的拆除计划，以拆除那些无法修复的房屋。市政府估计他们大约有4万栋房屋需要拆除。奥兰多·贝利是底特律东区的一名社区组织者，他说该计划的推出过程非常混乱。他们真的是在边飞边造飞机，我引用的是当时一位市政府官员说过的话。房子在全市范围内被拆除，但对于许多居民来说，拆除的速度还不够快。
Orlando says people in his neighborhood were pulling their hair out, hoping that the house next door would get demolished sometime soon. And what made it worse was they couldn't get any information from the city, explaining when it was going to happen. It was an acute level of frustration. Frustration with really just not being armed with the knowledge of how something that is affecting everybody in the city is working. And when the city struggled to provide information to residents, they would come to Orlando with questions. I remember my phone ringing on the hood all the time.
奥兰多说，他所在社区的人们急得抓耳挠腮，希望隔壁的房子能尽快拆除。更糟糕的是，他们无法从市政府那里得到任何关于拆除时间的信息。这是一种极度的挫败感。这种挫败感源于对影响城市中每个人的事情是如何运作的缺乏了解。当市政府难以向居民提供信息时，他们就会带着问题来找奥兰多。我记得我的电话总是响个不停。
Can you say some of those questions? There's this house on my block, it's been vacant for years. Is it coming down? So if the house is torn down, next to me, can I buy the lot? I don't know if you can buy the lot yet. I don't know. I can't really imagine how mad I am, you must have felt.
你能说出其中一些问题吗？我街区有栋房子已经空置多年了。它要拆了吗？如果我旁边的房子拆了，我可以买下那块地吗？我不知道你现在能不能买那块地。我不知道。我真的无法想象你当时一定感到有多愤怒。
Being in limbo, and it's a tough place to be. It was a crazy time. The residents of Orlando's neighborhood were experiencing a lot of anxiety about the economic situation in the city generally, and the fact that so many of the houses on their blocks were empty and falling apart. But the thing that was getting people to pick up the phone in Colorado was the act of waiting itself.
处于这种不确定的状态，是一个艰难的处境。那是一段疯狂的时期。奥兰多社区的居民对城市整体的经济状况感到非常焦虑，而且他们街区有那么多房子空置并逐渐破败。但真正让人们拿起电话打给奥兰多的，是等待本身。
The sentiment that I hear over and over again is how long must I wait? Waiting is something that we all do every day. We wait for our food to come and our operating systems to update. We wait for our food to come and our operating systems to update. We wait for our friends to call and our crushes to text us back. Our experience of waiting and how we feel about it varies radically depending on the context. And it turns out that design can completely change whether a five minute wait feels reasonable
我反复听到的心声是：我还要等多久？等待是我们每天都在做的事情。我们等待食物送达，等待操作系统更新。我们等待食物送达，等待操作系统更新。我们等待朋友回电，等待心仪的人回复短信。我们对等待的体验以及对此的感受，会根据环境的不同而产生巨大的差异。事实证明，设计可以彻底改变五分钟的等待是感觉合理，
or completely unbearable. For the Detroit residents waiting for abandoned houses to come down, the experience was pretty unbearable. For the Detroit residents waiting for abandoned houses to come down, the experience was pretty unbearable. And so the city set out to design a solution for them. And to do that, they turned to a body of research that offers insights into the strange psychology of waiting. The research didn't come from studying city government. It came from studying the particular frustration that people feel when they're waiting for a computer to load.
还是完全无法忍受。对于那些等待废弃房屋拆除的底特律居民来说，这种体验相当难以忍受。对于那些等待废弃房屋拆除的底特律居民来说，这种体验相当难以忍受。因此，市政府着手为他们设计一个解决方案。为了做到这一点，他们求助于一系列研究，这些研究提供了对等待这种奇怪心理的洞察。这项研究并非来自对市政府的研究，而是来自对人们在等待电脑加载时所感受到的那种特殊挫败感的研究。
Push a button and the words and images you see on the screen appear on paper. Oh, thank you. You know Fred, I think everybody on the road should see this. In the early 1980s, computers were just becoming popular in offices for the first time. And companies like Xerox were making work faster. Push another button, and the information is sent electronically to similar units around the corner or around the world. And in 1981, Xerox came out with its latest, quickest, top-of-the-line machine, an office computer called the Xerox Star. The Star was one of the first machines that allowed people to connect and share files
按下一个按钮，屏幕上看到的文字和图像就会出现在纸上。哦，谢谢。你知道弗雷德，我认为路上的每个人都应该看看这个。20世纪80年代初，电脑首次在办公室流行起来。像施乐这样的公司正在让工作变得更快。再按一个按钮，信息就会以电子方式发送到附近或世界各地的类似设备上。1981年，施乐推出了其最新、最快、顶级的机器，一款名为“施乐之星”的办公电脑。之星是首批允许人们连接和共享文件的机器之一，
and do things at a speed that they really hadn't done before. The star was one of the first machines that allowed people to connect and share files and do things at a speed that they really hadn't done before. This is Jason Farman. He's a professor at the University of Maryland, and he wrote a book about waiting called the lead response. And he says that even though the star was one of the fastest computers of its time, it didn't feel fast. Overwhelmingly people felt that it was a slow machine. Overwhelmingly, the
并以他们以前从未有过的速度完成工作。之星是首批允许人们连接和共享文件的机器之一，并以他们以前从未有过的速度完成工作。这是杰森·法曼。他是马里兰大学的教授，写了一本关于等待的书，名为《滞后反应》。他说，尽管之星是当时最快的电脑之一，但它感觉并不快。绝大多数人觉得它是一台慢速机器。绝大多数，
sentiment was that it took forever, it took forever to load, it took forever to exchange files. And that perception of slowness may have had something to do with the design of loading icons. These early computers like the Star were the first to use them. On the Star, the mouse cursor would turn into a static hourglass icon. Macintosh's from the same time had a wristwatch icon that was stuck on 9 o'clock. Every single time you saw the hourglass or the wristwatch, you knew you had to wait again. So you get the busy watch, but you don't know if it's actually making progress or not? That's Brad Myers. He's a computer science professor at Carnegie Mellon University,
人们的感觉是它加载需要永远，交换文件需要永远。而这种缓慢的感知可能与加载图标的设计有关。像之星这样的早期电脑是第一批使用它们的设备。在之星上，鼠标光标会变成一个静态的沙漏图标。同一时期的麦金塔电脑有一个卡在9点钟位置的手表图标。每次看到沙漏或手表，你就知道你又要等了。所以你看到了忙碌的手表，但你不知道它是否真的在取得进展？那是布拉德·迈尔斯。他是卡内基梅隆大学的计算机科学教授，
and he says that the problem with the watch was it gave you no sense of how long you would be waiting for. It might finish soon, it might not finish at all. And remember, you can't use the computer for other things. So really, the only option is to sit there and watch nothing happen or the cursor blink. I mean, that's to me, that sounds terrible. Exactly. Eventually, computer programmers started animating
他说手表的问题在于它让你无法感知还要等多久。它可能很快就会完成，也可能根本不会完成。记住，你不能用电脑做其他事情。所以真的，唯一的选择就是坐在那里看着什么都不发生，或者看着光标闪烁。我的意思是，对我来说，这听起来太糟糕了。没错。最终，计算机程序员开始对
loading icons to try to reassure the user that something was going on inside that mystery box. Apple introduced a spinning black and white pinwheel. Eventually, there were wristwatches with hands that moved and hourglasses with little falling pixels of sand. These new loading icons may have been more interesting to look at, but Jason Farman says
加载图标进行动画处理，试图向用户保证那个神秘盒子里正在发生一些事情。苹果引入了一个旋转的黑白风车。最终，出现了指针会动的手表，以及带有下落像素沙粒的沙漏。这些新的加载图标可能看起来更有趣，但杰森·法曼说，
they didn't fix the underlying problem. Here I'm trying to use my time well, but I can't control that because I'm waiting. Somebody is making me wait or a system is making me wait and I don't know when it's going to end. It is this deep feeling of powerlessness, I think. Around this time, Brad Myers had just finished his bachelor's degree at MIT, and he was working at a tech company. While he was struggling with these new loading icons, he remembered that older computers from the 1970s had a very simple way to let users know that the computer was working.
它们并没有解决根本问题。我在这里试图好好利用我的时间，但我无法控制，因为我在等待。有人让我等待，或者系统让我等待，我不知道什么时候才会结束。我认为这是一种深深的无力感。大约在这个时候，布拉德·迈尔斯刚从麻省理工学院获得学士学位，并在一家科技公司工作。当他为这些新的加载图标而苦恼时，他想起20世纪70年代的老式电脑有一种非常简单的方法让用户知道电脑正在工作。
Dots. Not unusual for programs in the 70s to print out a dot on the screen every now and then, so you would know that it's at least making progress. And the dots came at regular intervals, like one every seconds. So it would go dot dot dot right. And so then you'd say oh well must be making progress I keep seeing dots. And eventually you might have a sense for well, must be making progress, I keep seeing dots. And eventually, you might have a sense for, well, this is a fairly long program I'm expecting three rows of dots, or this will be a whole screen full of dots.
点。70年代的程序偶尔在屏幕上打印出一个点并不罕见，这样你就知道它至少在取得进展。而且这些点以固定的间隔出现，比如每秒一个。所以它会显示点、点、点，对吧。然后你会说，哦，好吧，它一定在取得进展，我一直在看到点。最终，你可能会有一种感觉，好吧，这是一个相当长的程序，我预计会有三行点，或者这将是满屏的点。
Myers says that having that little bit of information about the progress the computer was making made the experience of waiting much more bearable. So he reasoned that new computers needed a way to let the user know how long something might take. A progress bar. We're all familiar with this. The bar fills up as the computer works, showing how much of the task is completed. And Maya says the first progress bars were a huge improvement. Just by seeing how quickly the bar filled up, users could guess how long the computer would take to finish the job.
迈尔斯说，拥有关于电脑进展的那一点点信息，让等待的体验变得容易忍受多了。因此他推断，新电脑需要一种方法让用户知道某件事可能需要多长时间。进度条。我们都对此很熟悉。随着电脑的工作，进度条会填满，显示任务完成了多少。迈尔斯说，第一个进度条是一个巨大的进步。仅仅通过观察进度条填满的速度，用户就能猜出电脑完成工作需要多长时间。
You can say, okay, well, it the computer would take to finish the job. Myers started programming progress bars into everything he did. Then when he went back to graduate school to get his PhD, he actually studied progress bars and found that people really liked them. They made people less anxious. Myers published his findings in 1985 and people took notice. Progress bars started remove the worry. Maya's published his findings in 1985, and people took notice. Progress bars started popping up everywhere. People were so enthusiastic about this, because they finally got some feedback in a way that
你可以说，好吧，电脑完成工作需要多长时间。迈尔斯开始将进度条编程到他所做的一切中。后来，当他回到研究生院攻读博士学位时，他实际上研究了进度条，发现人们真的很喜欢它们。它们让人们不那么焦虑。迈尔斯在1985年发表了他的研究结果，人们开始注意到这一点。进度条开始消除担忧。迈尔斯在1985年发表了他的研究结果，人们开始注意到这一点。进度条开始随处可见。人们对此非常热情，因为他们终于以一种
this hourglass didn't give them. But there was one scenario where the progress bar failed, when the computer was stalled right at the very end. Progress bars gave users an accurate depiction of how much a task had been completed at any given time. And so, if the first 10% loaded in 10 seconds, then well, you'd think, well, the whole thing should be over in about 100 seconds, except it didn't always take 100 seconds. Sometimes the computer would slow down over some computational speed bump.
沙漏没有给他们的方式获得了一些反馈。但有一种情况进度条失败了，那就是电脑在最后时刻卡住了。进度条给用户提供了在任何给定时间任务完成程度的准确描述。所以，如果前10%在10秒内加载完成，那么好吧，你会认为，整个过程应该在100秒左右结束，但它并不总是需要100秒。有时电脑会在某个计算速度瓶颈上慢下来。
The progress bar would be sailing along and stall at 99% and you'd end up feeling completely betrayed. You leave the experience much more frustrated than you would if you just had this opaque buffering icon spinning in your browser. That revealed something really key about the psychology of waiting. Why things often feel slower than they really are? It's all about our expectations. And this is true on our computers and it's true at lines at Disneyland You look at it. It tells you how long it's gonna take and you set an expectation and when you get to the front of the line
进度条会一路顺畅，然后在99%处卡住，你最终会感到完全被背叛了。你离开时的挫败感比仅仅看到浏览器中那个不透明的缓冲图标旋转要强烈得多。这揭示了关于等待心理的一个关键点。为什么事情往往感觉比实际更慢？这完全取决于我们的期望。这在我们的电脑上是这样，在迪士尼乐园的排队中也是这样。你看着它。它告诉你需要多长时间，你设定了一个期望，当你到达队伍的最前面时，
Faster than you thought you were going to or when that particular piece of software loads faster than you thought it was going to, you leave the encounter feeling positive. That realization about expectations led designers to a new idea. A loading bar that had nothing to do with how much work the computer had done. Instead, it was designed just to make the weight feel better. It would always start off slow to set your expectations for a fairly long weight and then speed up at the end, so that the user ends up feeling pleasantly surprised. So that's one way that designers have given people
比你想象的要快，或者当那个特定的软件加载速度比你想象的要快时，你离开时会感觉很积极。这种关于期望的认识引导设计师产生了一个新想法。一个与电脑完成了多少工作无关的加载条。相反，它的设计只是为了让等待感觉更好。它总是开始得很慢，以设定你对相当长等待时间的期望，然后在最后加速，这样用户最终会感到惊喜。所以这是设计师给人们的一种方式，
a sense of beating expectation and they leave the encounter feeling good about the experience. Wow, that was fast. This front loaded loading bar tricked you into feeling like you were waiting for less time than you actually were. And in the 21st century, that idea of trying to manipulate the user's experience of time really took off, especially with big online retail companies whose profits depended on
一种超越期望的感觉，他们离开时对这次体验感觉良好。哇，那太快了。这个预加载的加载条欺骗了你，让你觉得你等待的时间比实际要短。在21世纪，这种试图操纵用户时间体验的想法真正流行起来，特别是在那些利润依赖于
keeping customers on their website. Amazon had done a study that showed that if customers on average are forced to wait a tenth of a second they could lose up to 1% of their revenue. When you've got that many people feeling frustrated enough to leave your site because of the delays that are there, you're just talking a massive amount of money. Companies like Google and Amazon started pouring millions of dollars into speeding up their websites and engineering them so they would run faster.
留住网站客户的大型在线零售公司中。亚马逊做过一项研究，显示如果客户平均被迫等待十分之一秒，他们可能会损失高达1%的收入。当你有那么多人因为延迟而感到沮丧并离开你的网站时，你谈论的就是一大笔钱。像谷歌和亚马逊这样的公司开始投入数百万美元来加速他们的网站，并对其进行工程设计，使其运行得更快。
And as things got faster, we expected them to always be that fast. That made us notice more and more minute delays. And so, people running websites were basically locked into this constant race of trying to make those weights smaller and smaller, or at least feel smaller and smaller. But there were some companies that just couldn't keep up with the internet's rapidly accelerating pace.
随着速度变快，我们期望它们总是那么快。这让我们注意到越来越多的细微延迟。因此，运营网站的人基本上被锁定在这场不断的竞赛中，试图让这些等待时间变得越来越短，或者至少感觉越来越短。但有些公司就是无法跟上互联网飞速发展的步伐。
Travel websites, for example, needed their customers to wait several seconds while they searched for tickets. That might not sound long, but a few seconds can feel like an eternity online. For comparison, search engines like Google were loading results in less than a second. But one travel website designed a solution to waiting that would have impacts outside the digital world and would eventually find its way into the offices of the city government of Detroit. I came across this company, Kayak, right? Which is an online travel search engine
例如，旅游网站需要客户等待几秒钟，以便他们搜索机票。这听起来可能不算长，但在网上几秒钟可能感觉像永恒。相比之下，像谷歌这样的搜索引擎加载结果的时间不到一秒。但一家旅游网站设计了一个等待解决方案，它将对数字世界之外产生影响，并最终进入底特律市政府的办公室。我偶然发现了这家公司，Kayak，对吧？它是一个在线旅游搜索引擎，
that I think many people will be very familiar with. This is Ryan Buel, a professor at the Harvard Business School. He says that Kayak couldn't avoid making its customers' weight. They actually have to do a fresh query every time a customer wants to find a ticket, which meant that it was inevitable that Kayak would have to make its customers wait,
我想很多人会非常熟悉。这是瑞安·比尔，哈佛商学院的教授。他说，Kayak无法避免让客户等待。他们实际上必须在客户想要查找机票时进行一次全新的查询，这意味着Kayak不可避免地必须让客户等待，
as all travel search engines do. Kayak was trying to figure out what they could show their customers while they waited, and Bill says that the solution they came up with completely changed the way he understood waiting. They just said, hey, look, you know, why don't we just show them what we're doing? Instead of a progress bar, kayak designed an animation that showed the user not only what percentage of the job had been completed, but exactly what the search algorithm was doing
正如所有旅游搜索引擎所做的那样。Kayak试图弄清楚在他们等待时可以向客户展示什么，比尔说他们想出的解决方案彻底改变了他对等待的理解。他们只是说，嘿，看，你知道，为什么我们不直接向他们展示我们在做什么呢？Kayak没有使用进度条，而是设计了一个动画，不仅向用户展示了任务完成了百分之几，还展示了搜索算法正在做什么，
as it was doing it. Now we're searching United Airlines. Now we're searching American Airlines and you can watch the prices fall as tickets come in that have better rates. This was the first time that I had ever seen an organization really deliberately design a window into the operation. This little animation gave the user something that none of the other loading designs could. Radical transparency. When we make the process transparent to people, when we show people the work that's going on behind the scenes, it completely changes the way that we think about the weight in general.
以及它是如何做的。现在我们正在搜索联合航空。现在我们正在搜索美国航空，你可以看着价格下降，因为有更好费率的机票进来了。这是我第一次看到一个组织真正刻意设计了一个通向操作的窗口。这个小动画给了用户其他加载设计所没有的东西。彻底的透明度。当我们向人们展示过程的透明度，当我们向人们展示幕后正在进行的工作时，它彻底改变了我们对等待的整体看法。
Instead of thinking of waiting as robbing you of your time, suddenly you are spending your time on something worthwhile. In this case, users could see all the work that Kayak's algorithm was doing, and they could imagine that if they tried to do all that work themselves and check every single one of those airlines on their own individual site, it would take forever. And that causes them to appreciate and value the service more. And so Bill began a series of experiments to test that idea. In one, he and his team created a fake travel
不再认为等待是在掠夺你的时间，突然间你把时间花在了一些有价值的事情上。在这种情况下，用户可以看到Kayak算法正在做的所有工作，他们可以想象，如果他们尝试自己做所有这些工作，并在各自的网站上检查每一家航空公司，那将需要永远。这使他们更加欣赏和重视这项服务。因此，比尔开始了一系列实验来测试这个想法。在其中一个实验中，他和他的团队创建了一个虚假的旅游
search engine and had participants wait different amounts of time for their search results. In one scenario, they saw just a progress bar while they waited. In the other, they got a progress bar plus an animation that showed them what was happening behind the scenes. They got transparency. No matter how long people waited for service, they always perceived the service to be more valuable when it was operationally transparent. In fact, people who waited 55 seconds with transparency were as satisfied as users who got instant results. 55 seconds is an eternity on the internet. When we can see the head and work that's going on to serve us, it makes us less sensitive to the time that we're spending waiting. Kayak.com doesn't look like this anymore, but Biel says he now sees examples of this kind of
搜索引擎，并让参与者为他们的搜索结果等待不同的时间。在一种情况下，他们在等待时只看到了一个进度条。在另一种情况下，他们得到了一个进度条加上一个动画，向他们展示了幕后发生的事情。他们得到了透明度。无论人们等待服务的时间有多长，当服务具有操作透明度时，他们总是认为服务更有价值。事实上，等待了55秒并获得透明度的人，与获得即时结果的用户一样满意。55秒在互联网上是永恒。当我们能看到为我们服务所付出的努力和工作时，它使我们对等待所花费的时间不那么敏感。Kayak.com现在看起来已经不一样了，但比尔说他现在到处都能看到这种
transparency everywhere. I mean, I noticed examples of this now all the time in my life, right? So anytime I take a lift or an Uber anywhere, you know, you get to see where the driver is. The Domino's Pizza Tracker is one of my favorite examples of this. You can actually watch and you can see your pizza going through the process. Beowulf found that radical transparency doesn't just impact how people experience waiting on our computers or our cell phones. It can have interesting, surprising psychological effects on how people wait in the real, physical world.
透明度的例子。我的意思是，我现在生活中一直注意到这种例子，对吧？所以任何时候我乘坐Lyft或Uber去任何地方，你知道，你都能看到司机在哪里。多米诺披萨追踪器是我最喜欢的例子之一。你实际上可以观看并看到你的披萨正在经历制作过程。比尔发现，彻底的透明度不仅影响人们在电脑或手机上等待的体验。它还能对人们在现实物理世界中等待的方式产生有趣、令人惊讶的心理影响。
For example, he conducted an experiment in a Harvard dining hall where he set up cameras so that students waiting for their food could see the chefs who were cooking it and vice-versa. And it turned out that scene behind the scenes not only made the weight more tolerable, but the food tasted better. Now the customers tell us that the food is 22% better and the chefs are working 19% faster. That's weird. It is kind of weird, but be aware that there is something really important going on. There are so many instances where we wait and think what the hell is happening,
例如，他在哈佛大学的一个食堂进行了一项实验，他安装了摄像头，以便等待食物的学生可以看到正在烹饪食物的厨师，反之亦然。结果发现，看到幕后不仅使等待变得更容易忍受，而且食物尝起来也更美味。现在客户告诉我们食物好吃了22%，厨师的工作速度快了19%。这很奇怪。这确实有点奇怪，但要注意，这里正在发生一些非常重要的事情。有太多的例子，我们等待并思考到底发生了什么，
but with this kind of transparency, we see people's efforts and we appreciate them more. We see why we're waiting and waiting becomes less of a chore. And that's true whether you're waiting for someone to cook you a meal, or for a website to load, or for a city government to come and knock down the abandoned house next door. Ryan Beale had been publishing his research on transparency for a few years when it found its way into the hands of a man named Brian Farcus, Farcus is the director of special projects at the Detroit Building Authority. The agency responsible for managing the city's demolition program.
但有了这种透明度，我们看到了人们的努力，我们更加欣赏他们。我们看到了为什么要等待，等待就不再那么像苦差事了。无论你是等待别人为你做饭，还是等待网站加载，或者等待市政府来拆除隔壁的废弃房屋，这都是事实。瑞安·比尔发表关于透明度的研究已经几年了，当时它落入了一个名叫布莱恩·法库斯的人手中，法库斯是底特律建筑管理局的项目特别主任。该机构负责管理城市的拆除计划。
He started a job in 2014, and he says that at the time, residents were constantly calling the city with the same question. How long am I going to have to wait for the city to demolish this abandoned home on my block? One is this burnt out house coming down. One is this house coming down. It's been there for five years. And in the early days, we didn't have the information to be able to respond to them.
他于2014年开始工作，他说当时居民不断打电话给市政府问同样的问题。我还要等多久，市政府才能拆除我街区这栋废弃的房子？这栋烧毁的房子什么时候拆？这栋房子什么时候拆？它已经在那里五年了。在早期，我们没有信息来回应他们。
Marcus's job was to communicate with the public and answer these questions, except there was no system to actually get that information to people, and no way to explain why things were taking so long. He says Detroit residents would get really upset on the phone, and it quickly became a burden for his department. I mean, the hours that were spent
法库斯的职责是与公众沟通并回答这些问题，但没有系统能真正将这些信息传达给人们，也没有办法解释为什么事情需要这么长时间。他说底特律居民在电话里会非常生气，这很快成为他部门的负担。我的意思是，花费在
and just responding to basic calls like that, was extremely tough and extremely labor intensive. But then one day, Farcus stumbled upon Ryan Buell's research about transparency, and he thought, we need something like this for Detroit. And so he wrote Buell an email, and Buell immediately wrote back. The next day he responded, saying he grew up just outside
仅仅回应这类基本电话上的时间，是非常艰难且极其耗费人力的。但后来有一天，法库斯偶然发现了瑞安·比尔关于透明度的研究，他想，我们需要为底特律做点类似的事情。于是他给比尔写了一封电子邮件，比尔立即回信了。第二天他回复说，他在弗林特郊外长大，
of Flint, and was very interested in this process. And he's, in a sense, been the mentor of myself and this program. With Buell's mentorship, Farcus began working on something he caused the neighborhood improvement tracker. It would be a window into all the work that was going into the city's demolition program. And a way for people to track which houses were going to come down and win. One of the first people he reached out to was Orlando Bailey, the community organizer
对这个过程非常感兴趣。在某种意义上，他一直是本人和这个项目的导师。在比尔的指导下，法库斯开始着手做他称之为“社区改善追踪器”的事情。这将是了解城市拆除计划中所有工作的一个窗口。也是人们追踪哪些房子将要拆除以及何时拆除的一种方式。他联系的第一批人之一是奥兰多·贝利，他是故事开始时的
from the beginning of the story. He wanted Orlando to help him test the tracker and make sure that he was working. So my reaction was one of joy. And so it was, because we would finally have something that can track things in real time, where I can, something that was readily accessible for when my phone rang and it rang a lot back then,
社区组织者。他想让奥兰多帮他测试追踪器，确保它能正常工作。所以我的反应是喜悦。确实如此，因为我们终于有了一个可以实时追踪事情的东西，我可以，当我的电话响时，它在当时响得很频繁，有一个随时可用的东西，
I can go to and have answers. Farcas showed up to community meetings every month to answer people's questions and show mock-ups of the neighborhood improvement tracker. People gave him feedback. The residents there were all for it and began to tell Farcas, this is what needs to be on the tracker. Mm-hmm. Ha-ha-ha. Orlando says it felt like the city
我可以去查看并得到答案。法库斯每个月都参加社区会议，回答人们的问题，并展示社区改善追踪器的模型。人们给了他反馈。那里的居民都非常支持，并开始告诉法库斯，这就是追踪器上需要有的东西。嗯。哈哈。奥兰多说，感觉就像市政府
was finally being honest with them and showing that they were committed to making the demolition program transparent. The tracker launched in 2016. It's basically an interactive map of Detroit. All over the map are different colored pens that show houses that are scheduled to be demolished. You can type in your address and the map
终于对他们诚实了，并表明他们致力于使拆除计划透明化。追踪器于2016年推出。它基本上是底特律的交互式地图。地图上到处都是不同颜色的图钉，显示了计划拆除的房屋。你可以输入你的地址，地图
zooms in to your house and you can turn on what are the completed demolitions, what are the contracted demolitions, what are the planned demolitions. For demos that have already been contracted, the tracker shows an estimate for when that house will come down. If a date hasn't been set yet, it will give other information. You can see we're the sidelines for sale. We're a home is being sold. We're building permits being pulled. The torturers who don't have internet access can get all the same information by texting
会放大到你的房子，你可以开启查看哪些是已完成的拆除，哪些是已签约的拆除，哪些是计划中的拆除。对于已经签约的拆除项目，追踪器会显示该房屋预计何时拆除。如果尚未设定日期，它会提供其他信息。你可以看到我们正在出售的闲置地块。我们正在出售的房屋。我们正在申请的建筑许可证。没有互联网接入的居民可以通过发短信
a phone number. Orlando says the tracker didn't always give people the answer they were hoping for, but it was a relief just to have any information at all. Whether they like the answer or not, they had the answer. So it's like, oh, well, all right, thanks. I spoke with one resident named Barb Matinee. Barb is a lifelong Detroiter who stayed through all of the foreclosures.
到一个电话号码来获取所有相同的信息。奥兰多说，追踪器并不总是给人们他们希望得到的答案，但仅仅能得到任何信息就是一种解脱。无论他们是否喜欢这个答案，他们都有了答案。所以就像，哦，好吧，好的，谢谢。我采访了一位名叫芭芭拉·马蒂尼的居民。芭芭拉是一位终身的底特律人，她经历了所有的止赎。
We met outside her house, except for a set of wind chimes, it's quiet in her neighborhood. God, there's a lot of pride in Detroit. I think all in all of your hurts here, you know, it's always gonna be here. I mean, this is always home. This is always going to be home. Unless it's been really difficult to see Detroit go through some of those changes over the last few decades. It's almost like it happened overnight.
我们在她家外面见面，除了风铃声，她所在的社区很安静。天哪，底特律有很多自豪感。我想你在这里的所有伤痛中，你知道，它总会在这里。我的意思是，这永远是家。这永远会是家。除非看到底特律在过去几十年里经历了一些变化，这真的很困难。这几乎就像是一夜之间发生的。
You know, it's like we woke up one day and opened up our blinds and all this devastation in empty houses is what we saw. Barb had a vacant house next door that couldn't be fixed. She used to mow the house as long while she waited for the demolition. And before the tracker went live, it felt like the house would never come down.
你知道，就像我们有一天醒来，拉开窗帘，看到的都是这种破坏和空房子。芭芭拉隔壁有一栋无法修复的空房子。她在等待拆除时曾经修剪那栋房子的草坪。在追踪器上线之前，感觉那栋房子永远不会拆除。
Yeah, after you see it sitting there in the same condition and falling in for two years, you've seen the things sometimes that you're just, it's never going to go away. It'll go away the day that it falls in on itself. You know, but like I said, things aren't, things aren't really like that anymore. With the tracker, Barb says those feelings changed because she could see the demolition program progressing. It's like, oh, finally. Yeah.
是的，在你看到它以同样的状态坐着并倒塌了两年之后，你有时会看到这些事情，你只是觉得，它永远不会消失。它会在它自己倒塌的那天消失。你知道，但就像我说的，事情不再是那样了。有了追踪器，芭芭拉说这些感觉改变了，因为她可以看到拆除计划在推进。就像，哦，终于。是的。
Yeah, it's a good feeling. You know, a big sigh of relief because you know it's going to be soon. And then the day that they show up, you're like throwing a fiesta. You've got the balloons and party poppers and you're out here going live. Oh, it's finally happy. Occasionally, Barbara says she runs into problems that the tracker can't explain. The cause for delays don't always show up, for example. But she says she's been able to call the city
是的，这是一种很好的感觉。你知道，长长地松了一口气，因为你知道很快就会拆了。然后他们出现的那天，你就像在开派对。你有气球和派对礼花，你在这里进行直播。哦，终于开心了。偶尔，芭芭拉说她会遇到追踪器无法解释的问题。例如，延迟的原因并不总是显示出来。但她说她一直能够打电话给市政府
and get that information. And it's been easier to get answers from them ever since the tracker went live. I can look in there myself, or I can just call our district manager, and within a short period of time, she usually gets back with me and lets me know what's going on with it. And knowing what's going on with it. And knowing what's going on can be really powerful.
并获得该信息。自从追踪器上线以来，从他们那里得到答案变得更容易了。我自己可以在里面查看，或者我可以直接打电话给我们的区经理，在很短的时间内，她通常会回复我，让我知道发生了什么。而且知道发生了什么。知道发生了什么真的很有力量。
Knowing when the abandoned house in her neighborhood was going to be demolished, allowed Barbara and her neighbors to make plans for what to do with that land. When the house finally came down, Barbara bought that lot and built a community garden. So now we currently have over 40 raised beds. We have a solar greenhouse. So now we currently have over 40 raised beds. We have a solar greenhouse. And then back over here is an orchard. Yes, it's a great place to be. Yeah.
知道她社区里的废弃房屋何时会被拆除，让芭芭拉和她的邻居们能够为如何处理那块土地制定计划。当房子最终拆除时，芭芭拉买下了那块地并建了一个社区花园。所以现在我们目前有超过40个高架花坛。我们有一个太阳能温室。所以现在我们目前有超过40个高架花坛。我们有一个太阳能温室。然后回到这边是一个果园。是的，这是一个很棒的地方。是的。
No, it's, I mean, it's a beautiful garden. You're really, really is. Detroit's demolition program hasn't been perfect. Lots of people wanted demolitions to happen faster, and there have also been concerns that the program has moved too quickly and caused environmental contamination, and some people felt that the program
不，它是，我的意思是，这是一个美丽的花园。你真的，真的是。底特律的拆除计划并不完美。很多人希望拆除工作进行得更快，而且也有人担心该计划推进得太快并造成了环境污染，有些人觉得该计划
wasn't prioritizing the right houses. A lot of people I talk to just don't trust the city, and while the tracker certainly isn't going to fix everything, Ryan Beals says it's a good first step towards building a better, more transparent dynamic between the city government and its residents. I have to believe the city is better off for having made that decision. And having said, we're going to make this commitment to be transparent with residents. And by revealing the progress
没有优先考虑正确的房屋。我交谈过的很多人只是不信任市政府，虽然追踪器肯定不能解决所有问题，但瑞安·比尔说，这是朝着在市政府和居民之间建立更好、更透明的动态关系迈出的良好第一步。我必须相信，市政府做出这个决定会更好。并且说，我们将做出这个承诺，对居民保持透明。通过揭示进展
and revealing the hidden work that's going on, perhaps that will give people the confidence, you know, that they need to also invest in their homes, in their properties, and trying to make the city help bring the city back to life. Transparency can be messy. Sometimes it can reveal mistakes in the process that make you feel frustrated. But Buehl says that radical transparency
并揭示正在进行的隐藏工作，也许这会给人们信心，你知道，他们也需要投资于他们的房屋、他们的财产，并试图让城市帮助使城市恢复生机。透明度可能会很混乱。有时它会揭示过程中让你感到沮丧的错误。但比尔说，彻底的透明度
also means giving space for constructive feedback and dialogue. Right, we're all in this thing together. And the provision of transparency just ensures that we all have access to that information. And if we have access to that information, then we have the opportunity to engage in the process. And if we can do that, then we get to better places than we can without. And dual hopes that others can learn from Detroit and Kayak and design little windows into the processes that are so often opaque to the people who depend on them. Because we all depend on companies and governments and other institutions
也意味着为建设性的反馈和对话留出空间。对，我们都在这条船上。而透明度的提供只是确保我们所有人都能获得这些信息。如果我们能获得这些信息，那么我们就有机会参与到这个过程中。如果我们能做到这一点，那么我们就能比没有它时到达更好的地方。比尔希望其他人能从底特律和Kayak那里学习，并为那些对依赖它们的人来说往往不透明的过程设计小窗口。因为我们都依赖公司、政府和其他机构，
just live our lives every day. We're all waiting for something. We have another really fascinating story about waiting, but you have to wait just a little bit longer. Stay with us. All right, so I'm in the studio. I'm talking with Angus Chen who reported that piece. And one of the things I was thinking about is that even though there has been this innovation
只是每天过我们的生活。我们都在等待什么。我们还有另一个关于等待的非常迷人的故事，但你必须再等一会儿。和我们在一起。好的，所以我在录音室。我正在和报道那篇报道的安格斯·陈交谈。我正在思考的一件事是，尽管在加载图标方面已经有了这种创新
and evolution and more transparency when it comes to loading icons, some of them are still pretty opaque and pretty awful. Right, I mean, we still have things like loading spinners, including the most reviled loading icon of all time, the spinning wheel of death, or, as I like to call it, the candy land toilet of time. Oh god, that one's the worst.
和演变以及更多的透明度，但其中一些仍然相当不透明且相当糟糕。对，我的意思是，我们仍然有像加载旋转器这样的东西，包括有史以来最受诟病的加载图标，死亡旋转轮，或者，正如我喜欢称呼它的，时间的糖果乐园厕所。哦天哪，那个是最糟糕的。
I hate it. Yeah, I hate it too. And the reason why everybody hates it is, because this is the most opaque loading icon that you could probably possibly design. It just doesn't tell you anything. The only information it seems to convey to me is that nothing you want to have happen
我讨厌它。是的，我也讨厌它。每个人都讨厌它的原因是，因为这是你可能设计出的最不透明的加载图标。它根本没有告诉你任何事情。它似乎传达给我的唯一信息是，在你关闭所有东西之前，
is going to happen ever again on this computer until you shut it all down, basically. Yeah, I mean, for me, it's like there's nothing that you can do. You're just stuck here. And that's actually exactly what Ryan Buell said, who we heard from in the show. The spinning wheel of death just reminds you in kind of a painful, stabby kind of way that you're just waiting and you're kind of stuck. And it's interesting because I think that there are lots of experiences that we have in life that are more like the spinning wheel of death.
在这个电脑上你想要发生的任何事情都不会再发生了，基本上。是的，我的意思是，对我来说，就像你什么都做不了。你只是被困在这里。这实际上正是我们在节目中听到的瑞安·比尔所说的。死亡旋转轮只是以一种痛苦的、刺痛的方式提醒你，你只是在等待，而且你有点被困住了。这很有趣，因为我认为我们在生活中有很多体验更像是死亡旋转轮。
And then there are some instances in life that are maybe more thoughtfully designed. So there's one particular example of a really thoughtful, transparent design that Bill told me about. It's from Japan where they have one of the best train systems in the world, the Shinkansen bullet train system. It's really amazing. They've had basically no injuries in like 40 years of operation and it goes like 200 miles an hour. They're super clean and they almost always
然后生活中也有一些例子可能设计得更周到。所以有一个关于真正周到、透明设计的具体例子，比尔告诉过我。它来自日本，那里拥有世界上最好的火车系统之一，新干线子弹头列车系统。这真的很神奇。他们在40年的运营中基本上没有受伤，而且时速达到200英里。它们超级干净，而且几乎总是
arrive within six seconds of schedule. How are they able to pull all that off? So part of it is this whole routine they have worked out where the trains sit at the platform for 12 minutes before they leave the station again. It takes about 5 minutes for passengers to get on and off, which leaves only about 7 minutes for a cleaning company called Tesset to prep the train for the next trip. 7 minutes for a team of 22 people to clean a thousand seats. That's incredibly fast, but I can imagine if you're standing on the train platform and the doors are closed and you can't get into your train because they're cleaning it, that
在时刻表后六秒内到达。他们是如何做到这一切的？所以部分原因是他们制定的一整套例行程序，火车在再次离开车站前在站台停留12分钟。乘客上下车大约需要5分钟，这只剩下大约7分钟让一家名为Tesset的清洁公司为下一次行程准备火车。7分钟，22人的团队清洁一千个座位。这非常快，但我可以想象，如果你站在火车站台上，门关着，你因为他们在清洁而无法进入你的火车，那么
that seven minutes could really feel like a long time. Yeah, I mean, especially if you don't know why exactly you're waiting there. And I think that was turning a really bad dynamic because you have these disgruntled, unhappy workers who feel like they're doing a really difficult job. And then you have impatient travelers who are standing there not really understanding why they can't get into the train. That's the right in front of them. So, Tess, I needed to find a way to fix this somehow. And in 2005, they brought in a new leader, a guy named Taruo Yabe.
那七分钟真的会感觉很长。是的，我的意思是，特别是如果你不知道为什么你一定要在那里等待。我认为这变成了一种非常糟糕的动态，因为你有这些心怀不满、不快乐的工人，他们觉得自己在做一份非常困难的工作。然后你有不耐烦的旅客站在那里，并没有真正理解为什么他们不能进入火车。就在他们面前。所以，Tesset需要找到一种方法来解决这个问题。在2005年，他们引入了一位新领导，一个名叫Taruo Yabe的人。
And he changed a bunch of things, but there was one thing in particular that had a really big impact. He instituted transparency between the passengers and the people cleaning the train. And the way that he did it, it seems really subtle, but it was really effective. He changed the color of their uniforms from a pale blue, which blended into the body of many of these trains to a vibrant red, which stood out just much, much more on the platform. So it was transparency by just making the workers
他改变了很多事情，但有一件事特别产生了很大的影响。他在乘客和清洁火车的人之间建立了透明度。他实现它的方式，看起来非常微妙，但非常有效。他将他们的制服颜色从淡蓝色（这与许多这些火车的车身融为一体）改为鲜艳的红色，这在站台上更加突出。所以这是通过仅仅让工人
more visible. Yeah, exactly. I mean, if you think about how the uniforms look before, the workers were supposed to just be invisible, right? You, as a passenger, are standing there, you're waiting around, you don't see what's happening exactly, and you don't know why you're waiting. But when the uniforms make the workers pop, you can suddenly see that, like, oh, I'm waiting here because there's people cleaning the train that I'm about to ride.
更显眼来实现的透明度。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，如果你想想制服以前的样子，工人们本应只是隐形的，对吧？你，作为一名乘客，站在那里，你在等待，你没有看到到底发生了什么，你也不知道为什么要等待。但当制服让工人们跳出来时，你突然可以看到，哦，我在这里等待是因为有人在清洁我即将乘坐的火车。
Test-hated workers don't always wear red anymore. A lot of time cleaning crews on the Shinkansen train system were a low-husher, so they wear something like a bright flower in the hat. But the idea is basically the same. They want to stand out. They want to be as visible as possible. Because if you make it as visible as possible, people appreciate it, and therefore they don't mind waiting, right?
测试日的工作人员不再总是穿红色的衣服了。新干线列车系统的清洁工通常很低调，所以他们会在帽子上戴一些类似鲜花的东西。但其理念基本相同。他们希望引人注目。他们希望尽可能地显眼。因为如果你让工作尽可能地显眼，人们就会欣赏它，因此他们就不会介意等待，对吧？
Yeah, and that's kind of the idea, is they can suddenly see why they're waiting, right? They know that they're not just like waiting around for no reason. They're waiting for something that will improve their travel experience. And the other thing that Yabe did was he let the cleaners speak with the passengers, which was forbidden under the previous leader. So we provided transparency from the passengers to the employees and from the employees back to the passengers. And it completely changed the experience of working at TSA, but it also completely changed the experience of waiting for service on the shinkansen.
是的，这就是其中的理念，他们突然能明白为什么要等待，对吧？他们知道自己不是无缘无故地等待。他们是在等待能改善旅行体验的事情。矢部做的另一件事是允许清洁工与乘客交谈，这在上一任领导下是被禁止的。因此，我们为乘客与员工之间、员工与乘客之间提供了透明度。这彻底改变了在新干线工作的体验，也彻底改变了等待新干线服务的体验。
And it fundamentally changed the dynamics of those interactions. So in what ways did it actually change? So, well, for one, the trains are actually getting cleaned on time. So the system was working better overall. But test day workers were struggling a lot less to do their job. And that's probably because passengers were cleaning up after themselves a lot more.
这从根本上改变了这些互动的动态。那么它到底在哪些方面发生了变化呢？首先，列车确实能按时打扫干净了。所以整个系统运行得更好了。但测试日的工作人员在完成工作时遇到的困难也少了很多。这可能是因为乘客们更多地开始清理自己的垃圾了。
They could see one, there are people who are doing this work and then made them more conscientious about their environment and what they were doing. But it also sort of flipped this experience of waiting totally on its head. People started to ride the shinkansen so they could watch Tessa crews performing their work. In Japan, they call this the seven-minute miracle. Sometimes they call it shinkansen theater. So at the end of every cleaning, the crew does a bow and passengers applaud. So it isn't just we make the waiting process transparent and therefore easier to handle.
他们可以看到，有人在做这项工作，这让他们对周围的环境和自己的行为更加自觉。但这也在某种程度上彻底颠覆了等待的体验。人们开始乘坐新干线，就是为了观看测试日团队的工作。在日本，他们称之为“七分钟奇迹”。有时他们称之为“新干线剧场”。所以每次清洁结束时，团队都会鞠躬，乘客们会鼓掌。所以这不仅仅是让等待过程透明化，从而更容易接受。
It also just like the transparency makes people realize that everyone's working really hard and everyone wants to take pride in this train that they're on and it makes the world just better place in general when we recognize that people are doing hard work around this. I think that's a beautiful story. Well, thank you, Angus. Thanks, Roman. 99% invisible was produced this week by Angus Chen, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. Mixed in tech production by Sriviusif, music by Sean Rihall. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. Thresda team is Avery Truffleman, Joe Rosenberg, Delaney Hall,
透明度也让人们意识到每个人都在努力工作，每个人都想为自己乘坐的这列火车感到自豪，当我们认识到人们在周围做着艰苦的工作时，世界总体上会变得更美好。我认为这是一个美丽的故事。好的，谢谢你，安格斯。谢谢，罗曼。《99% Invisible》本周由安格斯·陈制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。混音和技术制作由斯里维西夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里霍尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。测试日团队成员包括艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、乔·罗森伯格、德莱尼·霍尔，
Chris Perrubay, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klotzger, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco in produced, Unradio Row, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc, on Instagram and Reddit too. The day I'm recording this right now is the show's ninth birthday. So thank you for listening.
克里斯·佩鲁贝、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克洛茨格，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街制作。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注。我录制这一集的今天正好是节目的九周年纪念日。所以谢谢你们的收听。
Thanks for all you've done for the show. If you want to give us a review on iTunes or share a favorite episode, that would be a great way to celebrate. You can peruse the entire archive and pick out your favorite episode on at nipi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢你们为节目所做的一切。如果你想在iTunes上给我们写评论或分享你最喜欢的一集，那将是庆祝的好方法。你可以在99pi.org上浏览整个档案并挑选你最喜欢的一集。RadioTopia，来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。